[Music]
[Applause]
what a Merry Christmas special it's been
and now it's time for the last Christmas
gift of the evening I'm going to get
Bibi her exclusive Oh finally here it is
that's the title of your special and you
didn't come up with Christmas I came up
with my Christmas and it's totally
different from regular Christmas regular
Christmas is supposed to be about
celebrating the birth of Jesus a man who
is selfless and kind to died for our
sins but I'm greedy and petty and you
die for my sins
I'm the opposite of Christ I'm the
Antichrist but I am a savior of myself
my family and some of the worst most
hateful ideas that decent Americans
thought were long dead stop waiting for
a Christmas miracle what you see is what
you get I'm not going to suddenly turn
into a Christian or a populist or a good
friend or a good father or become
presidential or even a politician who
actually believes what he says I'm me
get used to it wise up
[Music]
it's not
when you first began me gosh
what you want you can hardly stand it
though by now you know it's gone
[Music]
to stop
you're sure there's a cure
and you have finally found it
[Music]
one tray
well shrink you did
underground
[Music]
ah
going to start
it's not
going to stop
tell you eyes
[Music]
prepare LS for what you need boy aside
away
[Music]
it's not
stop
[Music]
Americans got more creative with their
civil disobedience and used the
Constitution as a weapon against the
main person who swore now hold it and
can you imagine if the Democratic Party
actually rally behind a coherent message
that speaks to the working-class people
icon they could even take my catchphrase
make America great again
it's the perfect slogan for whoever runs
against me in 2020 because I'm making
America a lot of things but great isn't
one of them I think I shot the coalbed
dad oh wait a minute
is that what I think it is it's calling
everyone
[Music]